after a year when inflation hit a
40-year high many people are looking for
a fresh start to their finances in the
new year more than a third of Americans
say they are in worse financial position
than last year but many expect things to
get better CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here to help set
your plans for 2023. Jill good morning
good morning all right so let's talk
about inflation that's the big story it
has been the big story all year round is
there any relief in sight next year I
think so because we've had five
consecutive months of inflation reports
the CPI where we've seen inflation
trending lower so through November
prices are up 7.1 percent from a year
ago that's down from a 9.1 percent
reading in June and we should see
continued progress on the inflation
front that is the good news though I
will just say 7.1 percent is still a
high inflation rate yeah 7.1 is still
high and that has had an impact on
retirement plans so what do people who
are getting close to retirement or who
are retired what do they need to be
thinking about well it's an interesting
thing because when you look at
retirement plans and the money you put
in we know that as people get older
their kids age they can put more money
away they just have more savings and
ability to save well part of the IRS
code gets adjusted with inflation so if
you look at 2023 you can put a lot of
money away so right now 401K 403 b you
can put in 20 500 in the year 2022 but
in 23 it goes up to 22 500 that's the
amount and if you're over the age of 50
you can make a catch-up contribution of
seventy five hundred dollars now if you
don't have a workplace plan you use an
IRA you can put up to sixty five hundred
dollars and a thousand dollars extra if
you're over the age of 50. and again
usually as people get older some of
their cash flow does loosen up and they
can put more money away so let's talk
about putting money away everyone at the
start of the year as you know says you
know this is the year I buckle down I'm
going to start a savings plan or I'm
going to start putting money away for
retirement or for kids education
um how should people go about planning
to do that because everybody says it at
the start of the Year very few people
actually follow through I feel I feel
like this is one of those areas where
technology has increased our ability to
reach our goals and here's why you can
lay out that goal I want to do better
but you can actually automate so much of
your savings and I think the most
important thing is to track your
finances there's tons of online
resources there's tons of apps that
allow you to do that you see how much
money you have available to put away
then automatically put money in savings
I like to call it the big three you
number one have an emergency Reserve
fund with six to 12 months of your
living expenses set aside number two you
pay down high interest debt to the best
of your ability and I know that that's
really hard for a lot of people but
tackle it and it will get done number
three you put as much money as you
possibly can into a retirement plan if
you can get those big three accomplished
and automate them as much as possible
you'll be far better off all right you
heard it here first America let me ask
you about Investors that 2022 was a
rough year Market was extremely volatile
fundamentals are strong the economy
seems to be getting stronger what should
people who are investing think about
next year here's what I think is most
important don't try to guess where
things are going you were in it for a
long time and even if you are 62 years
old and you say I'm going to retire in
three years I'm really scared remember
when you retire your money has to last
you for a long time so when you have a
plan you want to have a diversified
portfolio some stock some bonds some
cash some real estate and you want to
stick to your game plan one good idea
for this year is make sure you rebalance
your portfolio it will force you to sell
things that are up not so much up after
this past year but also repurchase
shares at lower levels and if you stick
to your game plan I think you'll be
pretty satisfied over the long term yeah
I'm very proud to say that when people
ask me how am I doing how is my
investment plan going I go I have no
idea because I really know I have a plan
that's where my future and my eyes are
set to and I don't worry about it month
to month right just stick with it stay
calm you'll be all right all right Joe
Schlessinger always great to talk to you
Jill thank you thank you